i honestly can't remember the last time
i made a phone call
i i don't think i've ever done that in
my life
ever never i don't think it's ever come
up
generation mute is the phenomenon where
we actually see young people
prefer to text and use social media to
communicate
rather than pick up a phone or have a
conversation with each other i talk to
my friends
on whatsapp twitter
sometimes or facebook messenger just
anything that's
typing days upon days of messages
obviously calling is the easier thing to
do but
i just i just don't like it
for me phone calls are actually the
worst my sister
lives in dubai she realized how awkward
i was on the phone and she
she asked me i don't want to put you in
a position where you're uncomfortable
is there a better way to contact you and
i said yes
via email please i don't know how to
handle
that side of me very well my friends i
still feel it find a bit weird talking
to them
um and hearing their voice and hearing
them you know
give real responses to things i don't
like it but i know that it's an
important part of
making connection with someone
text-based interaction is hard
because you lose everything that you
have when there's somebody actually
talking to you
so you don't only don't have a face you
don't have a voice you haven't got
emotion and intonation
and all the other stuff you're hearing
in somebody's voice when they're talking
to you
because you just have words
[Music]
it took me five years to answer a phone
call from my boss
when i answered the phone to her she's
like oh darren you answered
i'm like yeah surprise the problem for
employers
is that this generation mute
is very much a generation of people who
are most comfortable
typing and not talking what we've
noticed
is there is a change you used to bring
someone in you would automatically
assume they'd know how to
answer a phone and now those
basic skills or skills that we have to
train
in a place of work then voices
is king
how people deal with stressful
situations
is actually marked in how they use
communication skills in an interaction
so couples who deal with a stressful
situation
with positive affect and laughter in a
conversation
feel better than couples where one
person's laughing and the other person
is not laughing
so we get more bang for our buck
out of talking to each other than we do
from anything else
it probably is like a generation thing
obviously
our parents and grandparents did just
have house phones and they never had
mobiles or anything like that what
you're seeing
is a generation who don't need to pick
up the phone because
they're able to use text-based
interactions on their phones in a much
more
complex way
[Music]
people are marking their difference and
they're allowed to so young people are
allowed to say
when it's not doing it like you this is
how we communicate and we are not the
same as you
and that's a rolling pattern of change
you get it across
fashion you get it across all sorts of
different aspects of music and cultural
tastes and you get it and how people
choose to communicate
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video
you